there's no way she can come back Carrie
Ann Inaba shuts down a Kim Zolciak at
dancing returned the Bravo star was
disqualified from Dancing with the Stars
this week after she wasn't able to
perform following a mini-stroke that
landed her in the hospital
Kim's partner Tony Dovolani is hoping a
social media campaign can bring them
back into the competition
maybe that'll persuade them but but when
we caught up with judge at Carrie Ann
Inaba on the PETA 35th anniversary red
carpet Wednesday night she said no way I
feel bad for her but those are the rules
and you know I'm a strong a biter by the
rules I am the lift please so you know
the rules are important to me and so I
feel badly for it but it would be unfair
to the other competitors there's no way
she can come back but I think it's good
because now she can spend some time with
her family Dancing with the Stars is
very grueling and that's a serious thing
to have a mini-stroke
I want her to take good care of herself
so we wish you welcome